I feel good you know I feel great
actually
you know but every day is a struggle you
know I take a day by day LuAnn de
Lesseps gave her first live TV interview
since returning home from her second
visit for rehab just over a week ago I'm
gonna be thirty days sober tomorrow so
I'm celebrating the Real Housewives of
New York star got candid on megyn kelly
today I fell off the wagon and opened up
about relapsing after her ex-husband and
two children filed a lawsuit against her
that was devastating I felt betrayed I
felt so hurt by that because I really
wanted to move on and I had a girlfriend
with me and I said and she goes I love
making watermelon martinis I said I'm in
I used to drink those at bungalow 8
years ago and I love them anyway I had
two or three of those then I had I think
two bottles of Rose a by myself and then
I had probably a six-pack of beer some
the 53 year olds missed the real
housewives reunion taping checking
herself back into a treatment facility I
had to take care of myself first
ét recently caught up with the show's
executive producer Andy Cohen and he
promised there will still be answers
about Lou even without her there we
discussed everything that happened with
LuAnn this season and there's a lot of
new information filling in a lot of
blanks that all the other women they all
shed a lot of new light LuAnn first
checked into a treatment facility in
December 2017 after she was arrested in
Palm Beach Florida
on charges of battery on an officer
disorderly intoxication resisting arrest
with violence and crimes against a
person I'm not proud of what I did
I'm just praying for a good outcome and
and forgiveness
the reality star struck a plea deal in
July and pleaded guilty to battery
trespass and disorderly intoxication
[Music]